hi my name is Dakota Weiss I'm the
executive chef and part-owner of Estrela
the dish I created for today is a really
fun dish I think it's really interactive
and can be very fun for couples to make
we're gonna make a black truffle shrimp
mousse ravioli so the first thing you
want to do to make this dish is get your
pasta dough made so I can rest and
become nice and bouncy I think the most
difficult part of this dish is getting
your pasta dough correct you want it to
not be too wet and not too dry it's too
wet it's going to be mushy and not taste
great won't have that nice - some feel
to it if it's too dry it's not going to
roll out properly it's gonna break
that's not good either while that's
resting we're going to start to make the
shrimp mousse you just puree the shrimp
with some creams and cream cheese and
black truffle oil salt all these yummy
ingredients to make it a really nice
smooth texture inside the ravioli
while you're pureeing the shrimp it's
really just about making sure everything
is consistently moving that's really
just scraping the bowl making sure it's
seasoned once we have our filling made
we're gonna go ahead and start rolling
out the pasta dough if you're really
ballsy then you can roll it by hand but
I'd be quite impressed with someone
actually try to do that I feel like this
is a great dish for a couple to make
because it really is a team player
situation pulling out the pasta dough
cutting it putting the filling and they
really need to work together and make
this happen once we have our pasta
rolled out to the right thickness you're
going to wash it with a little bit of
egg wash around it you're going to take
your shrimp mousse and kind of pipe it
into the center of each of these little
circles and then by hand just kind of
pinch it like a little Halfmoon
while those are resting you're going to
take your panko crumbs some toasted
hazelnuts and some brown butter and
you're going to puree it all in the row
beaucoup and you want to kind of pulse
it and want to have like a sand texture
to it you don't want to completely
pureed you don't want it mushy you just
want to be kind of broken up a bit once
that's ready we're going to take it into
a saute pan just toast it up a little
bit more so it gets nice and crunchy and
then we're going to set that aside now
we're pretty much ready to put this dish
together we're going to take our
raviolis a little bit of chicken stock
and a little bit of butter and this is
called a gloss a and we're basically
going to reheat them in this gloss a
constantly moving your saute pan so
they're getting evenly cooked and evenly
coat
in this chicken butter broth we're gonna
garnish our raviolis with a little bit
of the hazelnut brown butter crumbs that
you made and that's a delicious
comforting exciting date night dish
[Music]